let's keep building our table of laplace
transforms and now we'll do a fairly
hairy problem so i'm going to have to
focus so that i don't so that i don't
make a careless mistake but let's say we
want to take the laplace transform and
this is a useful one
we want to take the actually all of them
we've done so far are useful i'll tell
you when the one we start doing not so
useful ones let's say we want to take
the laplace transform of the sine
of some constant
times t
well our definition of the laplace
transform that's that says that it's the
improper integral remember laplace
transform is just a definition it's just
a tool that has turned out to be
extremely useful
and and we'll do more on on that
intuition later on but anyways the
integral
from zero to infinity
of e to the minus st
times whatever we're taking the laplace
transform of
times sine
of a t
dt
and now we have to go back and and and
and find our integration by parts neuron
and mine always disappears so i we have
to reprove integration by parts i don't
recommend you do this all the time if
you have to do this on an exam you might
want to memorize it before the exam but
always remember integration by parts is
just the product rule in reverse so i'll
just do that in this corner so the
product rule tells if we have two
functions
u times v
and if i were to take the derivative
of u times v let's say that they're
functions of t these are both functions
of t i could have written u of x times v
of x that equals the derivative of the
first
times the second function
plus
the first function times the derivative
of the second now if i were to integrate
both sides i get
u v this should be review is equal to
the integral
of u prime v with respect to dt but i'm
just doing a little bit of shorthand now
plus the integral
of u v prime i'm just trying to help
myself
remember this thing and let's take this
and subtract it from both sides so we
have this integral
this integral
the integral
of u prime
v
is going to be equal to this
u v
minus
the integral of u
v prime and of course this is a function
of t there's a dt here and all of that
but i just have to do this in the corner
of my page a lot because i always forget
this and it and with the primes and the
integrals and all that i always forget
it one way if you did want to memorize
it you said okay the integration by part
says if i take the deri the integral of
the derivative of one thing and then a
function and then a just a regular
function of another it equals the two
functions times each other minus the
integral of the reverse right here when
you take the subtraction you're taking
the the the one that had a derivative
now doesn't and the one that
didn't have a derivative now does but
anyway let's apply that to
our problem at hand to this one
well let's make
we could go either way about it let's
make u prime is equal to
so let's say u prime we'll do our
definition u prime is equal to
e to the minus
in which case
u would be the antiderivative of that
which is equal to minus
1 over s
e
to the minus st
right and actually just so this is going
to be an integration by parts twice
problem so i'm just actually going to
define the laplace transform
as y that'll come in useful later on and
i think i actually did
a very similar example to this uh when
we did integration by parts but anyway
back to the integration by part so
that's u and let me do v in a different
color
so when v if this is if this is u prime
right this is u prime then this is v so
v
is equal to sine
of a t and then what is v prime
well that's just a
cosine of a t right the chain rule
and now we're ready to to do our
integral so the laplace transform and
i'll just say that's y
y is equal to
right y is what we're trying to solve
for the laplace transform of sine of a t
that is equal to
u prime v where i defined u prime and v
right that's equal to that you probably
the integral of u prime times v that
equals u v so u v so that's
minus
one over s
e to the minus
s t times v
sine
sine of
a t
minus
the integral
and when you do when you do uh
the integration by parts and you know
this could be a an indefinite integral
an improper integral or definite
whatever but the boundary stay so we
could still say from zero to infinity
zero to infinity of u
v prime so u is minus 1 over s
minus 1 over s
e to the minus s t
times v prime times a cosine of a t
a cosine
of a
t
fair enough
dt
well now we have another hairy integral
we need to solve so this might involve
another integration by parts which and
it does
so here let's see let's see if we can
simplify it about let's take the
constants out first let me just rewrite
this
so we get
y
is equal to minus
e to the minus s t
over s
sine
of a t
so you have a minus minus plus
a
over s
plus
a
over s right a divided by s and these
two negative signs cancel out
times the integral
from zero to infinity
e to the minus
st
cosine
of a t
dt let's do another integration by parts
and i'll do this in a purple color just
you know this is our second integration
by parts
over here
let's define
let's define once again let's define
u prime
u prime is equal to e to the minus st so
this is u prime
then u is equal to minus 1 over s
e to the minus s t
we'll make
v equal to cosine of a t
d is equal to cosine of a t the hardest
part about this is just not making
careless mistakes
and then v prime
i just want it to be in the same row is
equal to
what minus a
minus a sine
of a t right chain rule derivative of
cosine is minus sign so let's substitute
that back in and we get
we get this is going to get hairy if if
unless if
actually it already is hairy y is equal
to minus
e
to the minus
st
over s
sine
of a t
plus
a over s times
times
okay integration by parts
u uv so that's
minus 1 over s
e to the minus st
times v times cosine
a t
minus
the integral
minus the integral from zero to infinity
this problem's making me hungry it's
taking so much glucose from my
bloodstream i'm focusing so much not to
make careless mistakes anyway integral
from zero to infinity and now we have u
v prime so u
is
minus one over s
e to the minus
s t
that's u and then v prime
times minus a
so let's put that minus let's make that
minus cancel out with this one so that
becomes a plus
a sine of a t
sine of a t
d t
i'm starting to see the light at the end
of the tunnel so then let's let's
simplify this thing and of course we're
going to have to evaluate this whole
thing right from
infinity
actually we're going to have to evaluate
everything let's just focus on the
indefinite integral for now we're going
to take this whole thing and evalu let's
just say that y is the anti-derivative
and then evaluate it from infinity to
zero from zero to infinity
so this is equal to
y is equal to minus e to the minus st
over s
sine
of a t
now let's distribute this
minus
a over s squared e to the minus st
cosine
of a t
right okay now i want to make sure i
don't make a killer's mistake okay now
let's multiply this times this and take
all the constants out so we have an a
and an s
a over s
there's a minus sign we have a plus a to
the s
so we'll have a
minus
a squared
a squared over s squared times the
integral
from zero well i said i'm just worrying
about the improper or sorry the
the indefinite integral right now and
we'll take the we'll evaluate at the
boundaries later
e to the minus s t
sine
of a t d t now this is the part and
we've done this before it's a bit a
little bit of a trick with integration
by parts but this expression
notice is the same thing as our original
y
right this is our original y and we're
assuming we're doing the indefinite
integral and we'll evaluate the
boundaries later although we could have
kept the boundaries the whole time but
it made it even hairier so we can
rewrite this integral as y in fact that
was our definition
so we get and actually i just realized
i'm running out of time so i'll continue
this hairy problem in the next video see
you soon